this is a different kind of superhero  story they tell it right we got to take  you back before I squeezed this ass and  expanded I love you way too awesome  we can fight this cancers only my liver  lungs prostate and brain all things I  can live without what if I told you we  can make you better we can give you  abilities most men only dream of please  don't make the supersuit green or  animated one thing that never survives  this place it's a sense of humor we'll  see about that pop spice oh come on you  know leave me all alone here with less  angry Rosie O'Donnell  did I leave the stove on Oh [ __ ] you  are hard to look at a testicle with  teeth looks like Freddy Krueger  face-fucked a topographical map of Utah  exactly aunty  greetings munchkins hankering for a  little more action  I am very turned on  you